in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Alex
and Audrey are with us hey guys how are
you what's up Dave welcome welcome
honored to have you or do you live here
from Raleigh North Carolina fun well
that's a bit of a drive over from there
to Nashville a little bit did you fly or
Drive no we drove that's a bit of a haul
so you're here to do your debt-free
scream how much have you paid off paid
off $60,000 and how long did that take
you about four and a half years Wow very
cool making what kind of money starting
out about thirty thousand and this year
we're just a tad over eighty thousand
whoa that's a big change
yep so what caused that income change
you know just you know I I'm a real
estate agent
ELP with you and so you know getting
into sales and stuff like that that
really helped and and and so that's kind
of how that happened ah okay so you're
getting better and better at the
business that's right good for you
way to go congratulations so what kind
of debt was the sixty thousand bucks um
some of it with student loans credit
cards to cars just about everything we
had everything dog that broke its leg
that we finance guys were normal that's
right if you could finance it we
probably did yeah I'm fairly normal
folks so what happened four and a half
years ago that changed this changed your
story tell me that about the journey
yeah so around the 2008 election cycle I
got kind of sick of listening to the
political talk radio and so kind of got
turned on to you and and and started
listening to you and and agreed with
everything you said and then you know
2009 we decided to buy a house when we
were flat broke and I thought the rules
didn't apply to me I thought everything
was that Dave Ramsey thought was good
except for you know me buying a house I
thought I was ready and and so that was
kind of a little bit of a disaster and
so we ended up having to to sell that
house and and and so that was kind of
rock-bottom for us and so you know from
from that point we kind of drew a line
in the sand and said you know we're done
we're not borrowing any more money and
so you know from there it was just kind
of went from listening to doing that's
right okay so odd ray what tell me that
conversation he comes home and says
okay I've been listening to this guy but
now we're actually going to do it or you
came up with the idea or what happened
it was mostly him he's the idea guy the
good ones and the bad guys we're cutting
up my credit cards okay and that was a
that was hard but I knew that we could
not continue just living off of debt and
not having any money so so which one of
these debts that when you paid it off
you went I'm so glad that's gone I'd say
this student loan we paid that off about
three months ago Sallie Mae gets her
eviction papers yeah you no longer live
with us old lady into the street yeah I
love it very cool yeah it was you know
it's it's kind of interesting because
our story is not a perfect one and
that's kind of you know I was thinking
of a you know leading into this event
for us you know kind of wanted to think
about the message I wanted to convey to
the other listeners out there and our
story was was very far from perfect and
it's you know we you know we took you
know three steps back and then four or
five steps forward it's just that
constant constant back and forth of
heading in the right direction and you
have some setbacks and you gotta take a
step back and regroup what was the worst
setback emotionally that you didn't know
if you were gonna get back on track
after that one you know I I think you
know for a long time it was it was
really tough because you know I I didn't
go to college and so I quit I equate a
lot of my career history to to gaining
in education so one of the toughest
things is there were there were some
years where our health care expenses
were a large part 25% of our our annual
income and so that that was really hard
to swallow when those years we just we
made literally note in the attraction
you know we just had to survive through
that year and we were we were very good
from the beginning to say we're done
we're not borrowing money it's not an
option and and we were and we still
struggle a little bit with with living
on a budget we're good at living on on
what we make but this process could have
been a little bit quicker if we had
mastered the budget and so you know that
was the toughest thing for us is is
learning to budget I mean we you know we
didn't borrow a dime through this whole
whole process but you know but telling
our money where to get
we struggled with that a little bit yeah
so you're proof that if you work it hard
enough you can do it anyway yeah yeah
yeah and it was you know and you kind of
have to shift your mind to when we were
talking about this this morning you have
to shift your mind to where debt is no
longer an option and and once you get to
that point you know it may take you two
years it may take you five years but
once you get to that point then it's
just hard work it's exactly right
but that's what happened to us and that
we just took that as an off the table
something comes up borrowing money what
an option so we just had to figure out
another way to do it and we just changed
once we did that that was a huge
breakthrough in they even Sharon
Ramsey's journey on this so well
congratulations you two
yeah very proud of you one more thing
it's kind of like you know growing up
you know your parents always have this
discussion to tell you you know when you
see drugs you say no to it and the
decisions already made and so when you
get to that point in your personal life
with with them with debt and with
financing things then the decisions
already made you don't have to think
about it when you're walking into the
store or your your friends get a new car
and and you know you don't even have to
think about it because it's not an
option and so I think that's that's
really important and I think that's kind
of the the key to us you know making it
through this process and getting out of
debt that's a that's well said I tell
leaders all the time that have trouble
making decisions in leadership that if
you have a strong value system your
value system already made most of your
decisions yep you already know what
you're going to do yeah I was just doing
it is the pain in the butt that's the
thing so well congratulations you guys
very very well done very proud of your
honor to have using the LP and Alex and
Audrey Raleigh North Carolina $60,000
paid off an imperfect process but a
perfect result four and a half years
from 30 to $80,000 worth of income
during that period of time count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
love it love it love it well done you
too
well done I love it
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show I want to write a song I want
to own my own business I want to make
more money
those aren't goals those are wishes my
New Year's resolution is to make more
money this year so wish